under horrible circumstances I really
feel for you and your family I really
got triggered because of OJ is Twitter
feed I don't know you a listen to that
at all um I stomach it it's not
something that feels great and I can't
really avoid it because it keeps coming
up when somebody kills your brother and
they're there on the golf course and
they're sitting there in their golf cart
living a life that I mean most people
don't get to live it's a pretty good
life
it's got to be maddening I think Jane I
think when he you know that the yours
truly and the laughing and the chuckling
about everything I just that part is
really hard to stomach because I look at
him and think rage murderer domestic
violence abuser it's just hard for me to
see him just enjoying you know the good
life like he likes to refer to it yeah I
mean I I didn't even realize I went back
and was looking in a research and stuff
and your brother was 25 years old money
was murdered and and and she was 35 I
mean these are people who didn't get to
live their lives yeah you think Twitter
should throw a offer what do you think I
say yes what do you say why do I say yes
because what would be the grounds how
would you have to have I don't need
grounds I own Twitter
see if I on Twitter a lot of people be
throwing up yeah I just think just that
just to save you the grief of seeing him
out there by the way he should use his
own head and to lay low you get away
with something like this
lay low my man well and that's the part
that I think was so confusing and then
it comes out in his first tweet as you
know I got some getting even to do and
then he talked about how he's not quite
dad I mean really that's the burning
question that's what you think you know
people want to know yeah and about and
some manager that you're the only one
that knows this guy's name you worried
about that I mean really